Oh what's fair buddy
we're confident it's time for the first
challenge episode of 2020 let's go okay
that's the first one so the next
challenge is to play with a Polaroid
picture of yourself ml say cheese
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah okay I think the photo I think so
I'll be playing with this you see the
from the horror film
[Music]
if there would be a picture of Malang
you'll just get oh yeah for sure but
luckily we have a picture for Thor so
yeah soon it's gonna be mayhem fine
[Music]
come on Oh how would have been good she
was gonna miss me Kaena
[Music]
so how does it feel that I'm playing
with you
these are probably the worst pictures of
us ever taken the chopstick for the
tickets let's see if you can do it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's take these two racquets together
[Music]
how are you supposed to play with this
[Applause]
[Music]
this feels a bit like pennies
[Music]
Oh Oh what
[Music]
okay I just hope that I get stuff gonna
come off
[Music]
so that would have been too good to be
better
[Music]
[Applause]
it's actually good to get a better rate
through it this one yeah I had to move
so much and I like this
I've dinner hit the robber but still a
good shot remembered subscribe to our
channel here and watch your previous
episode there until next time